Amigos, Venezuela puede estar a punto de experimentar
un cambio histórico.
Por primera vez da la sensación de que podemos
estar a puntito de presenciar el fin de la
revolución bolivariana.
Como todos sabéis este hombre, Juan Guaidó,
el Presidente de la Asamblea Nacional de Venezuela,
ha sido proclamado Presidente interino del
país.
Y la mayor parte de las potencias mundiales
y casi todos los países latinoamericanos
ya le han reconocido
como tal.
Todo ello junto a las nuevas sanciones de
Estados Unidos que han congelado los ingresos
del petróleo han puesto al régimen bolivariano
contra las cuerdas.
Amigos, el escenario al que se enfrenta ahora
Nicolás Maduro es complicado, muy complicado.
Por un lado su autoridad ha sido discutida
y la oposición popular es incontestable.
Por otro lado, el país está a punto de colapsar
del todo, porque, amigos, está a punto de
quedarse sin dólares y sin gasolina.
Sí, sí, sin gasolina, habéis escuchado
bien.
Hasta ahora Venezuela importaba un montón
de gasolina de Estados Unidos. Fijaos:
(Pdvsa importa 70% de la gasolina que consume
el mercado interno. El Nacional)
Pero claro ahora sin dólares… todo eso
se terminó.
[Y la pregunta es, ¿Puede un país sobrevivir
sin gasolina y sin petróleo? A mi me da que
no]
Y, ¿Sabéis qué? Nicolás Maduro y sus secuaces
lo saben, saben que su tiempo puede estar
a punto de terminarse… para siempre.
Pero… un momento. Llegados a este punto…
hay dos preguntas que tenemos que responder:
¿Cómo ha sobrevivido tanto tiempo este régimen
chavista, hoy pilotado por Nicolás Maduro?
Y, la segunda, ¿Será posible una transición
pacífica?
Amigos, son dos preguntas con los mismos protagonistas.
Atentos.
(LA GESTAPO BOLIVARIANA)
Amigos, no nos engañemos cambiar Venezuela
va a ser una tarea difícil, muy difícil.
Aunque se marcha Nicolás Maduro.
La revolución bolivariana no solo ha saqueado
y destruido la economía venezolana, también
ha creado un montón de redes e intereses
de todo tipo. Algunas de estas redes son precisamente
las que han permitido que Nicolás Maduro
siga hoy en el poder.
Hablamos de dos instituciones… claves en
todo el entramado chavista.
Una, la temible policía secreta del régimen,
organizada en el SEBIN, el Servicio Bolivariano
de Inteligencia Nacional. La otra las FAES,
las Fuerzas de Operaciones Especiales.
Hablamos de dos organizaciones que no han
dudado en secuestrar, encarcelar, robar, reprimir
y “dar de baja” a opositores y personas
a las que el régimen chavista consideraba
una amenaza.
Dos organizaciones que se han convertido en
la auténtica guardián pretoriana de Nicolas
Maduro… [Y que si se produjera un cambio
de gobierno, probablemente seguirían operando
en la sombra dedicándose a lo que ya se dedican:
el robo, la extorsión y el narcotráfico]
Pero, amigos, ¿Cómo surgieron estas organizaciones?¿Cómo
funcionan?¿Qué papel tienen realmente? Eso
es precisamente lo que vamos a ver.
(Esto no es algo nuevo. Todas las dictaduras
suelen utilizar grupos armados para consolidar
su poder, para alimentar el miedo a discrepar
del gobierno y ya puestos para eliminar opositores.
Tal vez, a lo largo del siglo XX los 3 casos
más conocidos han sido los de Mussolini que
tuvo a su servicio a la Organización para
la vigilancia y la represión del antifascista;
los de Stalin con el “Comisariato del Pueblo
para asuntos internos y el de los nazis con
la Gestapo.
La misión de todas estas organizaciones no
fue mantener la seguridad o preocuparse por
la justicia, sino consolidar el poder de sus
gobiernos dictatoriales.)
Pues bien, en el caso de Venezuela esto no
es diferente. La función de estos cuerpos
pasa por proteger a personajes como Diosdado
Cabello:
(¿Declaración de Rubio?: https://youtu.be/ik0JL-eFE-k?t=477
)
Y, amigos, a medida que la crisis económica
ha ido creciendo, estos dos grupos armados,
el SEBIN y las FAES han ido incrementando
su actividad.
Sin ir más lejos, tras el juramente de Guaido
como Presidente, Nicolas Maduro ha utilizado
estas organizaciones para tratar de frenar
las protestas publicas. Y aquí os hago una
pregunta, ¿Sabéis qué métodos han utilizado
para tratar de lograr su objetivo?
Seguro, seguro que acertáis porque siempre
es él mismo. Tan solo en la primera semana
tras la proclamación de Juan Guaido se calcula
que 35 personas fueron dadas de baja, fueron
víctimas de estos criminales, y más de 800
fueron detenidas.
(EL “TRABAJO SUCIO” DE LA REVOLUCIÓN)
Con el supuesto objetivo de combatir la creciente
violencia que vivía el país, en 2015 Nicolas
Maduro creo la OLP, la "Operación de Liberación
del Pueblo”…un despliegue… cuyos resultados
fueron terribles para los venezolanos:
Fijaos, entre 2015 y 2016 se calcula, atentos,
en 18.000 los casos de detenciones arbitrarias,
allanamientos sin orden judicial y ejecuciones.
Con toda esa experiencia en 2017 el régimen
creó las FAES, las fuerzas de acciones especiales,
un grupo de intervención con un entrenamiento
especial y procedimientos muy particulares.
Fijaos:
(“Primero, toman militarmente una zona,
como si se tratase de un ejército de ocupación
y proceden a "cazar" a sus objetivos. No se
trata de la seguridad ciudadana en la que
se debe prevenir o detener en el marco de
la legalidad a un delincuente, NO, en su caso
ellos entienden que tienen que llegar a dar
de baja a ‘elementos’ que no son personas
sino enemigos del régimen”. Keymer Ávila)
(“Las FAES están actuando en los barrios
populares con efectivos uniformados de negro
y dotados con sofisticados equipos de combate”.
José Vicente Rangel, exvicepresidente de
la República y exministro de defensa.)
Amigos, para que nos entendamos podemos decir
que las Faes han hecho de la brutalidad su
bandera. Y, ojo, no solo llevan a cabo operaciones
arbitrarias con una brutalidad enorme, también
se han convertido en muchos casos en auténticos
grupos criminales que han hecho del robo,
el crimen organizado y la extorsión toda
una fuente de ingresos.
(Y todo lo hacen de la mano de los llamados
“colectivos”, grupos parapoliciales creados,
armados y financiados por el régimen chavista.
Fueron creados en 2002 con la idea de controlar
directamente los barrios.
De esta forma, los venezolanos que discreparan
del régimen ya no estarían controlados sólo
por la policía y los servicios de inteligencia.
También por algunos de sus propios vecinos…
)
Controlados... y, por supuesto, atemorizados.
Porque, amigos, en muchos casos estos colectivos
ejercen su propia autoridad y een no pocas
ocasiones han montado sus propios negocios
ligados al narco y a la extorsión.
Pues bien, las FAES suelen montar operativos
de la mano de estos “colectivos”.
[¿Os imagináis otro país donde la policia
actue de la mano de bandas criminales? Bueno,
ahora que lo digo se me ocurre otro país:
Nicaragua. ¡Anda! Mira por donde, otro aliado
de Maduro]
Por su parte, el SEBIN, el poderoso Servicio
Bolivariano de Inteligencia Nacional creado
por Hugo Chávez en 2010 no se queda atrás.
Los agentes del SEBIN, símbolo de la represión
en Venezuela son los encargados de las operaciones
más delicadas como la detención y persecución
de opositores, aunque se trate de Diputados
de la Asamblea Nacional, del Parlamento Venezolano.
(“El Sebin se ha convertido en uno de los
símbolos del terrorismo de Estado que se
ha venido implantando en Venezuela. Es un
organismo que ha desarrollado una política
de graves violaciones a los derechos humanos”.
Marino Alvarado)
Amigos, a día de hoy estos dos grupos operan
con total impunidad y en la sombra.
Del Sebin, por ejemplo, no se sabe con cuantos
agentes cuenta el cuerpo, a cuantas personas
tiene realmente detenidas, o quien manda en
sus diferentes departamentos.
Lo único que sabemos es que está bajo las
órdenes de este hombre: Manuel Cristhoper
Figuera, que podría ser controlado en gran
medida por Tareck El Aissami, vicepresidente
económico de Venezuela, un tipo que es considerado
por los Estados Unidos como todo un narco.
Sabemos eso y que este servicio opera con
tanta impunidad que incluso hace caso omiso
a los propios tribunales bolivarianos.
Si, me explico. Se sabe de muchos casos donde
presos políticos a los que la propia “justicia”
bolivariana ha ordenado poner en libertad
siguen en la cárcel porque al SEBIN simplemente
no le da la gana soltarlos.
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, este edificio
que veis en las imágenes es la tal vez la
mejor prueba del desastre que ha sufrido Venezuela
durante las últimas décadas.
Veréis, me explico. Este edificio de aspecto
futurista que evoca a la Torre de Babel, el
Helicoide, empezó a construirse en 1956 para
albergar un centro comercial y un hotel de
lujo. Hoy es una de las dos principales sedes
de SEBIN. Aquí es donde tiene sus calabozos.
Unos calabozos que como seguro ya os imagináis
tienen unas condiciones terribles.
(“Los calabozos no tienen baños ni te garantizan
atención médica. A los presos los tienen
encerrados casi siempre, pueden pasar semanas
o meses para que te dejen salir por algunos
minutos al exterior.
Jamás se me olvidará que el inspector que
me recibió tras mi detención me dijo: “Bienvenida
al infierno”. Vilca Fernández, ex candidato
a la Asamblea Nacional)
Y sí, los agentes del SEBIN cobran a las
familias por llevar, por ejemplo alimentos
a la carcel. Dinero que, por supuesto, va
al bolsillo de los agentes.
Pero’, ¿Sabéis cuál ha sido el resultado
que han dejado tras de sí estos grupos en
los últimos años?
Pues según las informaciones de la Organización
de Estados Americanos, podríamos estar hablando
de más de 8.000 ejecuciones, fundamentalmente
a manos de estos grupos, tan solo desde el
año 2015.,
Y, ojo, porque los datos del Observatorio
Venezolano de la Violencia son aún peores.
Según esta organización tan solo en 2018,
los cuerpos de seguridad habrían dado de
baja a más de 7.500 personas.
Amigos, estos dos grupos no solo han sido
el brazo armado de Nicolas Maduro, su soporte
vital para mantenerse en el poder. Si no que
llegada la hora del cambio probablemente sean
todo un quebradero de cabeza. Si hoy estos
grupos ya tienen vínculos con el Narco no
sería nada extraño que luego esta se convierta
en su actividad principal.
Pero de todo eso ya hablaremos.
Ahora turno para ti. Te hago una pregunta
clave: ¿Crees que hay que ofrecer una amnistía
por todos sus crímenes a los lideres que
han secuestrado, saqueado y destruido a Venezuela?
Déjame tu respuestas en los comentarios y
también - que nos lo pedís mucho - en esta
encuesta.